à la une du figaro ce matin
le duel décisif avec un sondage qui
montre le rn en tête au premier tour 39
mariani 35 muselier au second mariani
l'emportent en cas de triangulaire et
c'est super serré si la gauche se retire
évidemment qu'il faudra se retirer au
second tour évidemment que la question
du front républicain appelons cela comme
ça et poser un trucage le dit depuis le
début
le front républicain ça n'existe plus en
réalité qui croient sincèrement que la
république est menacée si on prend une
ou plusieurs régions passe beaucoup plus
de temps dans notre pays à penser à la
prochaine élection
plutôt qu'un réfléchir sur le fond à ce
qu'il faut faire pour le pays dans les
cinq dix quinze vingt ans qui viennent
on est rentré dans son parti à l'époque
où y'avait j'ai presque envie de dire
des géants comme pascouau se gagne qui
aujourd'hui ça finit par jacques hop ça
illustre toute la déchéance de ce parti
aujourd'hui ce parti surtout n'a plus de
conviction guillaume pelletier se
fourvoie il se fourvoie et et le
rassemblement national
il faut le connaître le voir de près
pour savoir ce que c'est c'est un parti
qui vit les problèmes et qui refuse
toutes les solutions monsieur bardella a
conduit une liste aux européennes sur la
lys une liste sur laquelle il y avait
jean françois jalkh
jean françois jalkh qui est aujourd'hui
député européen font front national et
qui a tenu des propos révisionnistes sur
les chambres à gaz
ce mercredi le retour de mein kampf
l'ouvragé dans lequel adolf hitler
détail sa doctrine et nazis c'était
avant de devenir dictateur à la fin des
années 1920
le livre est réédité en dix mille
exemplaires pour à historiciser le mal
c'est ce que dit la maison d'édition
fire face en dix ans après la mort de
l'auteur le copyright tongs et donc
n'importe qui peut le plus lié n'importe
comment
et d'ailleurs la première personne en
france qu'il a fait après 2016 c'est
alain soral et donc il fallait répondre
à cette situation en proposant un livre
qui est vraiment un livre comme ni serge
klarsfeld
un livre critique et éducatif contre
mein kampf le livre n'est pas à la
portée de tous puisqu'il coûte 100 euros
et n'est disponible qu'en commande et
non pas en librairie
il sera néanmoins possible de
l'emprunter aux bibliothèques
évidemment c'est très pointu un coup
lucratif depuis le début il est évident
que fayard gagnerez pas un centime en
publiant historiciser le mal et c'est
pour ça que grâce à serge klarsfeld on a
signé une convention avec la fondation
auschwitz birkenau
c'est une fondation polonaise qui est
chargée de la conservation des sites des
camps d'extermination d'auschwitz et de
birkenau
les indicateurs sont donc au vert au
niveau national c'est une bonne nouvelle
qui montre que la première étape
levée des mesures de restriction est
réussi et qu'elle n'a pas enrayé la
diminution de l'épidémie
nous avons décidé ce matin à partir du
15 juin et bien 12 de commencer à ouvrir
la vaccination pour les adolescents
enfin les plus jeunes et à partir du 15
juin de permettre aux 12 18 ans de
d'aller se faire vacciner
elle sera évidemment sur la base du
volontariat avec l'accord des parents
vous l'imaginez bien il ne sera en aucun
cas obligatoire et elle va participer de
ce mouvement d' immunité collective qui
nous permettra de nous l'espérons de
limiter des fermetures de classes de
collège ou de lycée à la rentrée autour
du volcan les gaz chauds et me
provoquent des turbulences et des plus
de pierres chaudes ce qui rend le
pilotage de ces engins encore plus
délicat grâce à la retransmission en
direct joey hand ça tout de même réussi
à récupérer les images captées par le
drone mais le crash et il volontaire ou
bien due à un incident technique le
pilote laisse planer le doute
je laisse à l'interprétation du
spectateur cela mène à des discussions
intéressantes
j'habite à dire la vérité au foot c'est
pas vrai